[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo ante la
situación de kobe 19 ahora trabajamos de
este caso la ciudad de glasgow acoge a
centenares de líderes mundiales en un
nuevo intento por hacer frente a la
crisis climática sólo los primeros días
de la cope que se hicieron mucho de que
hablar sobre todo en internet que se ha
convertido en un espacio importante para
el activismo en redes sociales los
internautas presionaron por medidas
concretas y expusieron el discurso de
sus líderes sus comportamientos y sus
compromisos con el medio ambiente en
esta edición de revista digital les
traemos los momentos virales de este
evento empezamos
la con 26 es quizás por estos días el
principal tema de la agenda mundial pero
más que el evento destinado a encontrar
soluciones para combatir el cambio
climático los ojos están puestos sobre
los líderes mundiales los compromisos y
las promesas de los mandatarios e
incluso el comportamiento de algunos de
ellos durante la cumbre dejaron mucho
que desear la ciudadanía cansada de
promesas incumplidas de sus dirigentes
estuvo vigilante y lo sometió al
escrutinio
por ejemplo uno de los grandes
cuestionados fue el presidente de eeuu
joe biden por cuenta de imágenes como
estas que se hicieron virales en redes
sociales se trata de la extensa caravana
de vehículos que trasladó al mandatario
por la ciudad de glasgow si el
transporte es una de las principales
causas de dióxido de carbono que hace
que nuestro planeta se caliente los
internautas no se explicaban cómo es que
byd en uso tantos vehículos para llegar
a un evento donde se discute
precisamente cómo reducir el
calentamiento global de acuerdo con
medios de comunicación locales la
caravana estuvo conformada por unos 20
vehículos antes de glasgow bailén ya
había dado de qué hablar en roma donde
estuvo para la reunión del g-20 allí se
transportó a bordo de una caravana aún
más extensa y en la que se crea había
más de 80 vehículos lo cierto es que no
se sabe cuántos de ellos eran eléctricos
o híbridos o si todos operan a base de
combustible
pero el descontento no solo gira
alrededor de joe biden bajo el
calificativo de ecos hipócritas los
usuarios en internet criticaron a los
líderes ejecutivos y otras
personalidades que viajaron a la cob 26
en sus propios aviones citando a fuentes
oficiales el periódico escocés sunday
mail informó durante el fin de semana
previo a la cumbre que unos 400 jets
privados aterrizarían en escocia según
la federación europea de transporte y
medioambiente este tipo de aviones
tienen un impacto desproporcionado para
el planeta ya que en sólo una hora de
vuelo pueden emitir dos toneladas de co2
mientras que una persona promedio en
europa emite 8,2 toneladas de co2 en un
año el grupo estima que estos viajes
lanzarán a la atmósfera unas 13.000
toneladas de co2 que es más que lo que
producen 1600 escoceses al año
ya en la cumbre expectantes los
asistentes mantenían los ojos bien
abiertos aunque algunos no tanto en su
cuenta de 'twitter' un periodista del
washington post publicó un vídeo del
presidente job aiden en el que se le ve
aparentemente quedándose dormido durante
los discursos de apertura de la con 26
por otro lado las cámaras habrían
captado al primer ministro del reino
unido- boris johnson en la misma
situación sin embargo no está claro si
se trató de un parpadeo o realmente se
quedó dormido ya que en una secuencia de
imágenes se le ve atento a más
publicaciones despertaron las críticas
tanto de sus opositores políticos como
de activistas que cuestionaron si en
realidad los mandatarios les interesaba
lo que pasa con el planeta otros los
defendieron asegurando que habían tenido
una jornada extensa durante el g20
algunos fueron más allá y confrontaron
directamente a sus líderes como sucedió
con el presidente colombiano iván duque
en este vídeo que circula en redes
sociales se hizo evidente el reclamo de
un grupo de sus compatriotas que exigían
al mandatario que tramitará con urgencia
atado de esta suv un acuerdo
multilateral de américa latina y el
caribe destinado entre otras cosas a
garantizar la protección de líderes
ambientalistas este se firmó en 2018
pero el congreso colombiano no lo ha
ratificado un informe de la ong global
witness reveló que en 2020 227
defensores del medio ambiente fueron
asesinados y que colombia registró el
número más alto con 65 casos por otro
lado en una carta abierta en la que se
califica de traición al fracaso de los
gobiernos para reducir las emisiones de
carbono los jóvenes exigen medidas
concretas se trata de una iniciativa de
la activista sueca greta tan ver junto a
otras líderes juveniles y en la que
piden por ejemplo mantener el
calentamiento global por debajo de los
15 grados centígrados frenar las
inversiones de combustibles fósiles y
financiar a los países más vulnerables
la petición se encuentra en línea a
través de la plataforma a base y
cualquiera puede sumarse el número de
firmas crece cada segundo en conclusión
han sido más los cuestionamientos que
los elogios a esta cumbre a la que los
activistas se han referido como un
festiva green washing un término que
podría reducirse como lavado verde
blanke amianto y es utilizado para
referirse a quienes se muestran al mundo
como defensores del medio ambiente con
el único objetivo de limpiar su imagen y
hasta vender productos cuidar del medio
ambiente no es sólo ahorrar agua o
evitar tirar basuras en la calle sino
también reducir las emisiones de co2 que
como mencionamos anteriormente son las
causantes del calentamiento global
nuestras acciones diarias contribuyen a
ello y para saber cómo reducir estas
emisiones es importante saber que tanto
co2 estamos produciendo como individuos
en internet existen diversas
herramientas útiles solo basta con
escribir en el buscador calcular mi
huella de carbono y aparecerá un
sinnúmero de páginas la web de la ong
greenpeace por ejemplo le dará un par de
preguntas sobre sus hábitos de consumo
diarios y le mostrará cuánto dióxido de
carbono usted está emitiendo al año y de
qué manera está afectando al planeta
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir esta u otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www puntos 24
punto com